[Musique]
françoise le marchand bonjour merci
d'être sur le plateau de tv 78 aline le
grand bonjour merci aussi d'être avec
nous pour ce vide qui vous est consacré
à toutes les deux vous êtes yvelinoise
versaillaise et vous avez une actualité
en cours à savoir un nouveau livre qui
vient de sortir un livre de
photographies que vous avez alors on dit
pas illustré puisque les situations
c'est l'image donc ce sont vos photos et
que vous avez comme on dit pour la
personne qui crée des textes à côté des
photos qui accompagnent les images
accompagner vos mots boudiaf 1 j'ai
accompagné avec windows me vois très
bien on va dire accompagner revient
alors on va remonter un tout petit peu
dans le temps
françoise vous avez sorti un autre livre
anne ans en 2018 avec votre époux
françois lemarchand qui raconte une vie
d'explorateurs
d'ailleurs c'est lui qui quittera en
explorateur voilà on voit l'image car il
faut dire que vous êtes à l'initiative
des magasins l'installation des magasins
pier import en france c'est une très
très longue histoire qu'on va faire très
courte
après une très longue rhuys histoire
d'une vie une partie de vie et après
vous avez initié les magasins nature et
découvertes dont le tout nouveau siège
d'ailleurs est à versailles
voilà donc à travers ce livre que vous
avez créé à deux on apprend à vous
connaître
quand même parce que les photos sont en
majorité les vôtres voilà il ya votre
écriture
en marge de ces photos et une fois vous
titre d'ailleurs un moment j'ai la
chance d'être une mère et d'avoir des
enfants ce qui me permet d'avoir un
contact facile avec d'autres enfants que
je ne connais pas et de pouvoir faire
des photos donc déjà à cette époque là
vous aviez votre appareil à la main oui
voilà vous avez travaillé donc images et
l'image de nature et découvertes aussi
j'imagine vous êtes occupé des
catalogues
oui je me suis occupé de là j'ai créé
l'identité visuelle voilà on peut dire
voilà de naturel découverts mais selon
qu il y avait des catalogues c'est vous
qui faisait les photos voilà vous mettez
en valeur les objets voilà
prenez vos enfants comme le modèle
petits-enfants nos pas non mes petits
enfants parce que c'était mal à s'étirer
pas encore là et mais mes enfants petit
oui beaucoup
mais mes neveux et nièces mes petits
voisins
voilà c'était une époque on vous pouvez
travailler en famille et faire des
choses un petit peu après tu et qui
était du coup très naturelle et ce qui
s'est avéré très rapidement impossible à
faire puisque aujourd'hui pour faire des
photos d'un enfant il faut tout un
paquet de l'autorisation unique de
normes mais à partir de quel moment où
vous vous êtes dit je suis photographe
professionnel c'était toujours dans
votre tête où il ya une évolution
je me suis je suis photographe
professionnel quand j'ai commencé quand
j'ai vu ma première couverture dans je
crois que c'était chez votre déco qui
n'existe plus d'ailleurs
voilà où j'évite tout d'un coup que
j'avais la couvre donc là je me suis dit
c'est je suis arrivé à ce que je voulais
parce que j'avais fait énormément de
photos avant pour pier import
tout ça dans un cadre qui était assez
familial v et le jour où j'ai commencé à
travailler dans la presse leurs familles
or we hors famille hors contexte oui or
pier import et confort de votre voilà
donc j'ai fait de la pub j'ai travaillé
pour d'autres d'autres de toujours notre
magazine
oui j'ai travaillé pour pas mal de
magazines et la maison voilà il mais
j'ai fait de la pub également ah oui à
la grande époque de la pub où on avait
des débuts j'ai qui nous permettait de
faire des photos qui était voilà dépôt
catalogue d'accord et de partir loin et
voilà et vous avez aussi initié une
revue qui s'appelle kbp oui oui j'ai
démarré une revue donc à l'intérieur de
maisons nature et découvertes
oui absolument le cadre de nature et
découvertes pour ce que j'avais fait
beaucoup de catalogue ou en vendée
beaucoup d'objets et j'avais envie de
deux de faire passer notre message que
qu'un message marchand si je puis dire
et avec des objets j'avais envie de 10
matériel en en faisant parler des
auteurs en que vous appelez des passeurs
des passeurs des photographes des
écrivains des sociologues
voilà c'était une revue qui dans la
baseline était pour une écologie de la
terre du corps et de l'esprit mais qui
était pour moi les collégiens lebel
mystique et université anglo bête tout
un univers qui n'était pas qu'ils
n'étaient ou absolument pas seulement un
univers mercantile jeu pour prendre un
autre rituel est plein de choses oui il
y avait la fondation nature et
découvertes en plus votre relation très
rapidement aussi donc très bien alors on
va revenir juste canopée votre revue
c'est là je crois que vous avez
rencontré à lille le grand alors je
connaissais aline oui je connaissais
aline parce qu'elle est mon ami et je
connaissais son écriture et j'aimais
beaucoup son écriture et
j'ai eu un j'avais 13 ans piller un jour
de faire un sujet sur l'art dans les
chapelles puisque aline est prêt très
impliquée dans l'art l'art contemporain
ce listing un état absolument donc je
lui ai demandé de faire le texte pour ce
sujet de l'art dans les chapelles
voilà donc adopté dans canopée une
dizaine ou une douzaine de pages très
merveilleusement écrit par par amine il
y est voilà et après je me suis toujours
dit que un jour avec aline il faudrait
qu'on fasse quelque chose ensemble
d'accord parce que aujourd'hui donc sur
ce livre sans jeux d'hiver aversa et
malama delayed en son jardin
donc comme on disait tout à l'heure
voilà accompagné des modèles il le grand
photo vous avez prises vous donc comment
vous vous êtes organisé toutes les deux
c'est vous qui dites moi vous avez eu
envie d'aller découvrir le parc sous la
neige parce que ça se trouve
sinon j'ai fait envie d'aller découvrir
le parc sionnel j'ai regardé j'habite
versailles
quarante ans que j'essaie donne le parc
à toutes les saisons tout le temps voilà
parce que le parc pour moi et un est un
bienfait et je trouve tout dans le parc
se trouve de l'esthétique je trouve du
silence de troupes de la méditation je
trouve de la beauté je trouve de la
mystique
j'ai des milliers de photos du parc à
toutes les saisons
je suis retombé récemment sur une série
que j'ai fait il ya très longtemps que
j'avais fait avec un film qui s'appelle
le pôle apens qui est un polaroïd qu'il
donnait s'était fait un petit peu de 2,2
du grain avec en noir et blanc surtout
mais aussi en couleur et je me suis dit
tiens un jour ça serait bien que je
fasse quelque chose avec cette série qui
est un petit peu particulière je
développe et moi même le film ça s'était
très artisanal et j'adore l'artisanat et
je me suis dit je vais reprendre ses
photos pour essayer d'en faire quelque
chose d'accord j'ai pensé à aline tout
de suite et je me suis dit aline qui a
elle-même sillonné le parc en long en
large et en travers à toutes les saisons
qui a écrit beaucoup déjà aussi je vais
on va faire qualifier dans les
formations
alors du coup est-ce que vous avez
choisi les photos ensemble ou pas et
après comment vous êtes organisé parce
que il ya un souci tout de même madame
adelaïde en son jardin
alors c'est pas très connu cette madame
un des leaders ou l'historienne c'est
vous qui l'avez y avait eu l'idée
racontez moi
elle s'est imposée à moi je pense avril
qu on peut dire qu'il s'est déjà alors à
david et la quatrième fille de louis 15
finalement je me suis dit ce parc a été
fortement marquée par l'histoire d'une
famille ne veut pas donc n'importe quel
parc
et même si je partage avec françoise
c'est émerveillement et et ces moments
est tellement intime dans ce parc que je
me réapproprie aussi à ma façon mais je
me suis vraiment aussi identifié à cette
princesse qui a vécu quasiment toute son
existence à versailles et je me suis dit
que ce parc était peut-être un espace de
liberté et son espace où elles pouvaient
rêver et je les imagine et revenir comme
dans un rêve dans ce parc qui a été le
parc de son enfant jusqu'à ce jusqu'à
son départ en exil en design final il va
rester voilà pour la libye at il
effectivement et alors elle plus qu'une
autre parce qu'elle était plutôt rebelle
elle a refusé d'aller au couvent elle a
refusé de se marier est ce qu'elle ait
eu un chagrin d'amour
alors c'est vous qui l'avez inventé j'ai
rien avant qu'elle a eu effectivement
une tocade amoureuse en tout cas comme
elle était très impulsive et ardente de
tempérament elle est tombée amoureuse
d'un garde du corps de son père et elle
lui a envoyé de façon anonyme une
tabatière 1 et elle était assez
maladroite il faut le dire parce que
cette tabatière avait été offert par le
voir à sa fille parce que lui même
tourné le bois lui 15 on ne sait pas
toujours
et évidemment donc ce jeune officier
s'est retrouvé avec cette tabatière
d'une femme inconnue
il en a référé à son supérieur qui en
arrivent à des endroits évidemment la
ferraille qui cognait et si contrôle
très rapidement puisque les jeunes a été
renvoyé dans sa province
mais avec une bonne pension donc ce
n'est pas si mal sorti donc voilà les
amours de madame adélaïde c'est tous les
ans des cours oui l apache une vie
amoureuse dont on a beaucoup parlé et je
pense que si elle avait vraiment une
vieille
on en aurait parlé parce qu'à cette
époque là vous aviez des observateurs la
cour et que tout se savait d'accord
alors est ce que vous auriez envie de
nous lire peut-être un peu ce texte
si vous me dites non je suis bien embêté
je vous le passez alors se passer une
photo je la montre je sais pas si c'est
une photo qu'on a eu à l'écran mais
c'est pas grave
quel format on les photos exposées parce
qu'il faut qu'on dise après ve
oui parc de l'expo après oussema fils en
il ya des il ya des très grands formats
qui sont la plupart en noir et blanc il
ya des formats plus petits qui sont en
alors quand je dis très grand format
c'est 95 par 135 d'accord après et puis
les formats plus petits et non non non
certaines photos en couleurs aussi
qu'ils sont très aussi sous la neige
oui surtout le thème c'est c'est ce
thème à d'accord qui est le parc sous la
neige ce qu'est et voilà c'est le
sinistre 105 on parle pas que du livre
on parle d'une expo avenier donc qui
démarre le 15 décembre qui va durer
jusqu'au 19 janvier qui sera à
versailles dans la galerie anagama
anagama qui est tout décalé du marché du
lait xacti des antiquaires alors c'est
le sait le marché à côté du marché
demain activement dans le dans le
quartier des antiquaires et c'est une
très jolie galerie et qui avec deux
femmes qui tiennent ces galeries qui
sont encore des femmes donc avec une une
sensibilité on a essayé c'est une
histoire de femmes à nos deux adélaïde
notre éditrice c'est ces deux femmes est
très belle expo à la bombe à écouter on
va finir sur les modalités le grand si
vous voulez bien nous livre un petit
texte
sakineh une seule nuit pour dénouer fil
par fil le canevas de nos existences
pour livrer notre rang nos maisons nos
parterres à la jachère révolutionnaire
bon ça s'est bien terminé pour elle oui
quand même
oui bon éventuel quand même
68 ans qu'il est pour les potes à
l'époque il va tout à fait honorable bon
l'exil à trieste d'accord ben écoute et
françoise le marchand annie legrand et
drôme acide est venu nous parler toutes
ces belles choses donc pour ceux qui
veulent en apprendre plus ce livre est
extrêmement riche sur une aventure de
couple entrepreneurs voilà et pour ceux
qui aiment les magnifiques photos le
côté un petit peu à peu et la poésie
d'aline et puis le côté apaisant un peu
feutré de la rrq la neige et ses photos
qui sont à la fois très graphique et
magnifique roland mais a très vite
merci aussi au revoir
[Musique]